una colecistectomía abierta es un
procedimiento quirúrgico para extirpar
la vesícula biliar a través de una
incisión grande en el abdomen la
vesícula biliar es una bolsa en forma de
pera debajo del hígado el hígado y la
vesícula biliar tienen pequeños tubos
que salen de ellos llamados conductos
estos conductos se unen en un conducto
grande que se adhiere al intestino
delgado el el hígado produce Billis un
líquido que descompone la grasa de los
alimentos en el transcurso entre una
comida y otra la mayor parte de la bilis
fluye a través de los conductos hacia la
vesícula biliar y se almacena allí
cuando está comiendo alimentos grasos la
vesícula biliar se contrae para liberar
la bilis almacenada en el intestino
delgado y el hígado libera más bilis que
fluye directamente al
intestino la colecistectomía
laparoscópica es la forma más común de
extirpar la vesícula biliar en ella se
utilizan herramientas insertadas a
través de pequeñas incisiones en el
abdomen sin embargo es posible que
necesite una colecistectomía abierta si
no puede realizar una colecistectomía
laparoscópica de manera segura en una
colecistectomía abierta se realiza una
incisión en la parte superior derecha
del
abdomen dentro del mismo el cirujano
separa la vesícula biliar del
hígado luego el cirujano sujeta y corta
el conducto y la arteria que conducen a
la vesícula biliar y le extirpa la
vesícula al final del procedimiento la
incisión se cierra con grapas puntos o
pegamento para la
piel una vez que le hayan extraído la
vesícula biliar aún podrá digerir la
grasa porque la bilis fluirá
directamente del hígado al intestino
delgado si tiene preguntas sobre la
colecistectomía abierta hable con su
médico
H